we have an incredible start to the news
today
the incredible amanda gorman is looking
absolutely radiant on the cover of vogue
that's right it's their may issue and
amanda is the first poet to
ever be on a vogue cover she's wearing a
louis vuitton blanket styled as a dress
designed by
virgil abloh louis vuitton's first black
artistic director
and he drew some of his inspiration from
an old photo of his grandmother in ghana
wearing a full kente look i just love to
see
this stunning powerful cover of vogue
ross okay this is iconic already like
instantly how proud she looks how they
pulled the green from the dress for the
vogue logo
it just is all perfection iconic is the
word
this woman is a true superstar and it is
all based on her soul her talent her
heart
her vision her poetry and i think she's
going to change the game for poetry as
we know
absolutely yeah there's like she's got
this message and this purpose for being
here
she's sharing it and i feel like we're
going to be talking about her for the
next 80 years
i really agreed to okay your story raw
look you well i was holding some oh good
well simon why don't you go over there
while i read this story taylor swift
her uh she her re-recorded album
fearless
uh remember she had it back in the day
well she's re-recording it and it drops
today and there's a spicy little track
on there
it's previously unreleased called mr
perfectly fine hi
uh and it's rumored to be about her ex
joe jonas remember how they dated yes
yeah well she wrote this like 12 years
ago fans are going crazy on twitter and
joe's white's wife sophie turner from
game of thrones right
she jumped in posting this to instagram
she goes well it's not
not a bop and apparently taylor wrote
the song that we said 12 years ago so
all's good
but it is this like time capsule right
you have dogs
sounds like it sounds like old school
taylor swift
i love this and what i really love most
of all
is that sophie turner is a confident
woman going i like this song
we're cool we don't need to start like a
ridiculous twitter beef
it's just cute and fun and celebratory
and girls celebrating girls and moving
on i love it and i also like fun to
think about like if you could open your
diary from 12 years ago
what you know what you were thinking
about what you're focused on yeah that's
interesting yeah
and oh by the way since it is diy week
around here we got a report that diy-ers
are
feeling the taylor love as well
apartment therapy says that there's a
new study
that looked into what music people most
like to listen to while they're diying
they pulled all the playlists labeled
with keywords like painting interior
design gardening
they analyzed over 70 000 songs and
found that the most listened to artists
was taylor swift what do you listen to
when you
are diying at home i'm a big tame impala
fan and i make a lot of playlists in
fact if anybody's interested
go on to spotify and i have numerous
playlists that i put out i'm gonna
subscribe to yours i listen to
uh donna summer pandora
a little disco around the house oh my
gosh i used to um
hang out with donna summer oh my god
[Music]
you